never have I ever met a more hated and
feared hormone than cortisol eating
clean and not losing weight cortisol
always thirsty and craving carbs
cortisol working out and yet gaining
belly fat cortisol cortisol
cortisol corol is the key factor in
explaining any disappointing disruption
to the predicted energy balance equation
it is the alleged reason why you just
can not seem to lose those last 10 lbs
or while your pants size is slowly
inching up every single year but is it a
legitimate factor or just the convenient
scapegoat as we say there's a lot here
to unpack hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to aby's
[Music]
Kitchen in today's video we'll be
talking about cortisol and weight gain
does it actually matter and what you can
do about it a big thank you to Eric
Williamson and his team at unlocked
Fitness and Nutrition for the support on
this script I will be linked to their
website below if you're looking for any
one-on-one support for evidence-based
weight loss as well as any kind of
Fitness Sports Nutrition they really are
the best and make sure to check out my
disclaimer and content notes we are
talking weight loss today and also to
get a link to my free Hunger crushing
coo ebook Okay so let me interrupt for a
hot minute here to talk about the
importance of sleep and my sponsor ate
sleep I like sleep do you guys like
sleep because as someone who has
struggled with insomnia for years eight
sleep has completely changed the game I
got so much great feedback from this the
last time I mentioned eight sleep so
clearly a lot of you guys feel the same
so the Pod cover by eight sleep fits any
bed like a fitted sheet and improves
your sleep by adjusting to your ideal
body temperature based on your needs
phases of sleep and environment I run
really really hot especially mid morning
when I tend to wake up too early while
my husband is always complaining that
it's too cold and the Pod cover allows
us to set the temperature of our bed
between 55 and 110° F on each side so
that we can both be comfortable and it's
not just about better Comfort there's
actual science to back this up so
resarch suggest that we fall asleep best
when the temperature drops between 1 and
3° F and then when we need to wake up
the temperature should gradually climb
so the Pod monitors your body's
temperature and adjusts it up and down
to keep you in the optimal zone for your
bed your preferences and the environment
it also tracks and collects data while
you sleep without you having to wear any
kind of uncomfortable wearable device
and it also can replace your blaring
alarm in the morning with a gentle chest
level vibration and a gradual increase
in temperature which helps you naturally
wake up without the unpleasant shock to
the system I fully realize that this is
a higher ticket item but I've really
come to realize over the past few years
of struggling with sleep that you just
cannot put a price on a good sleep we
have ample evidence that sleep is one of
the most important modifiable factors
contributing to health Mental Health
weight management Stress Management
immunity cognitive Health chronic
disease risk and more and the numbers
speak for themselves so P sleepers fall
asleep 44% faster and get into a 34%
deeper sleep it's honestly being
life-changing for someone like me so if
you want to try out the Pod cover
yourself you can check out the link in
my description and use my promo code
Abby to get $150 off of your order and
thank you again to eight sleep for
sponsoring this video you can check out
the link in my description and use my
promo code Abby to get $150 off of your
order all right I'm going to make my
kids some muffins here super quick
little overview cortisol is a stress
hormone that helps mobilize fuel for our
body to use as energy typically a
stressor is perceived by our brain which
then activates the sympathetic nervous
system to release adrenaline and
cortisol from the adrenal glands when
cortisol levels rise glucose fat and
protein get broken down and are released
into the bloodstream for our muscles to
utilize this means that it also
increases blood glucose levels again in
the assumption that our body needs that
energy to deal with the stressor at hand
so anytime people hear the word cortisol
or even stressor we immediately think
that's bad but cortisol stimulation is
actually essential in a lot of
situations transient increases in
cortisol like in the morning to get you
moving and out of the bed during or
following exercise and even during
stress like public speaking are all
positive signs of healthy cortisol
secretion without cortisol levels Rising
we would basically just be vegetables
that said chronically high levels could
make accomplishing certain health goals
more challenging so first let's talk
about cortisol and belly fat so
chronically High cortisol is associated
with both weight gain and having a
higher BMI in many but not necessarily
all studies so one study for example
found that those with high cortisol gain
1.12 kg over 6 months whereas those with
lower cortisol gain about. 53 kg also if
we look at something like Cushing
syndrome which is a medical condition
characterized by excessive cortisol
production we typically do see higher
belly fat and lower muscle mass
interestingly while cortisol can
increase the net fat breakdown across
the body it conversely results in a
decrease in fat breakdown around the
intraabdominal area and it's this belly
fat AKA visceral fat that is most
closely related to chronic disease and
this is really where the concern around
cortisol and health lies so how does
this all happen let's unpack first let's
talk about the association between high
intensity exercise and elevated cortisol
so exercise is actually a stressor on
the body and resar has shown that
intense exercise for an hour and 15
minutes results in a significant
increase in cortisol levels that's even
higher than those with a high cortisol
disease like Cushing syndrome now levels
do come down uh usually about an hour
and a half after the exercise and again
this rise in cortisol in response to
exercise makes physiological sense
cortisol's job is to break down fat to
make it available to muscle when you
need that energy so high cortisol during
after exercise is actually just kind of
a sign of an intense workout session I
really this up I should have mashed the
bananas before I added the
[Music]
mix but here we are but anyways it has a
stronger association with muscle gain
after strength workouts than
testosterone and growth hormone and when
cortisol is given as a drug it actually
improves exercise performance so this is
not all a bad thing and even though
exercise increases cortisol during and
following a workout it actually
decreases it at other times in the day
especially at nighttime so it's
important to note that regular exercise
overall actually reduces daily cortisol
levels even if we look at the research
on like Elite sprinters and look at
their like super intense training
sessions their cortisol levels on
average are lower than those who don't
exercise so I don't want anyone thinking
that exercise is suddenly bad in fact
High cortisol post exercise is actually
kind of what we want but this is where
things get a little complicated so a lot
of folks will suggest that exercising
too intensely like doing hit training
can lead to chronically High cortisol
levels which again is not what we want
and while there is some cases where
overe exercising can cause daily levels
of cortisol to climb it's generally
still more likely to reduce daily
cortisol except when you combine that
erex exercising with a restrictive diet
so for example some women who end up
losing their period because they
restrict calories and or carb and they
engage in high levels of activity tend
to have higher cortisol levels and a 7%
lower resting metabolic rate than would
be otherwise expected this relationship
isn't fully consistent and we also don't
really know if High cortisol levels
cause menstrual dysfunction and lower
metabolism or whether the cortisol is
just kind of like along for the ride but
this is just one example of the impact
that dietary restriction can have on
daily cortisol and I'm going to be
diving into way more of that in a moment
bottom line exercise might increase
cortisol transiently but overall it
actually has a cortisol lowering effect
and it's not until we get into under
fueling that exercise that we may be
putting our metabolism and hormones at
risk next let's talk about weight loss
diets on cortisol levels so dieting AKA
chloric restriction is another big
stressor on the Body Research suggest
that the greater the chloric deficit the
higher the cortisol levels with
long-term fasting AKA two or more days
without eating any anything resulting in
the greatest increases in cortisol and
this again makes complete sense
considering that the body would want to
break down all of its energy sources
when it's just not getting enough
through food now considering that we
made the association or the connection
that high cortisol can increase belly
fat storage and that dieting increases
cortisol it would make sense that high
cortisol is associated with impaired
weight loss right not so fast hold your
horses
research actually suggests that there is
no association with cortisol levels and
someone's ability to effectively lose
weight some studies actually find that
higher cortisol levels while dieting is
associated with higher weight loss
levels and this is not to say that high
cortisol increases weight loss it
actually does not again it can actually
cause belly fat storage as we discussed
but at the end of the day folks calorie
deficiency causes both an increase in
cortisol and an increase in weight loss
if you're in a calorie deficit it is
very unlikely that cortisol will make
you gain belly fat but it may mean that
you hold on to that belly fat while
losing from other places in the body
which again is usually not what we want
now when discussing inter fasting things
are a little more complicated again any
caloric or energy deficit will increase
cortisol but if we enter in Fast and we
skip dinner AKA will we call Early Tim
restricted feeding so let's say you know
you're eating from 8:00 in the morning
till 4:00 p.m. we actually don't see a
rise in cortisol and this is even in
cases where there's a chloric deficit
but in folks that skip breakfast a late
Tim restricted feeding which is what
most people do when they inter in fast
or maybe you're eating between like 12:
and 8:00 p.m. this is where we see a
significant increase in cortisol levels
at night and this is particularly being
demonstrated in those who practice
Ramadan fasting where cortisol levels
have shifted towards later in the day
and that actually has a detrimental
impact on people's sleep so diets
increase cortisol but that connection
doesn't seem to be directly impairing
weight loss even though it may
potentially make losing belly fat more
challenging now the more likely mediator
for impaired weight loss is food choices
and appetite in other words stress and
cortisol seem to impact food quality and
quantity more so than food choices are
impacting cortisol and stress so one way
to temporarily reduce our cortisol
levels is by eating delicious calor
dense food especially foods that are
high in sugar and fat and this is why we
typically crave foods like chocolate and
candy when we're stressed and obviously
these Cravings tend to be most intense
in folks who are also on a weight loss
diet cortisol also seems to increase our
hunger hormones like grin and make us
just want to eat more so one study found
that those on IV drugs that raise
cortisol levels eat 1.5 times more
calories than they normally would so
bottom line the hormone cortisol isn't
preventing weight loss it's likely just
making you crave more caloric foods that
make staying in a calorie deficit a lot
more difficult so corol may not be as
bad as Wellness culture makes it out to
be but we still don't want it to be
chronically high so how would you even
know if it was high in the first place
first of all if you're at all concerned
speak to your doctor about your symptoms
and ask for a referral to an
endocrinologist unfortunately the signs
of high cortisol are kind of so common
that they could be caused by a ton of
different things but some of the most
common ones are things like waking in
the midsection but nowhere else severe
fatigue slow wound healing muscle
weakness and muscle loss now there are
tests that are used in clinical practice
like the uh dexamethasone test 24-hour
urinary cortisol excretion and the
salivary cortisol test which tests
across the day now the at home death
test is a bit controversial but they do
offer a salivary cortisol that uses
similar essays to what is used in
clinical research I would just be wary
of some of their other hormone tests
that haven't been well validated or
proven to reliably test what they say
they do now in terms of what to do about
it it really depends on the cause if
someone is ovx exercising and they're
restricting their diet and as a result
they've got hypothalamic amenorrhea then
they need to exercise less and eat more
and this is where a dietitian could be a
really helpful player now now if it's
related to medication like medications
like ADHD meds or other health
conditions like Cushing syndrome then of
course you're going to want to talk to
your doctor about your options now
psychiatric disorders are actually the
most common cause of elevated cortisol
not dieting not exorcising as so many
people like to think in the wellness
culture even if you don't have a psych
disorder that's being diagnosed we know
that strategies like CBT meditation and
mindfulness exercises can all help to
bring those levels down bottom line
chronic levels of high cortisol can
cause fat redistribution to the belly
and belly fat is a real concern when it
comes to risk of chronic disease but if
you gain weight and fat and have high
cortisol it's not because cortisol is
reducing your metabolism it's not
because it's making you lazy or fatigued
and want to exercise less and outside of
the specific scenarios that we just
discussed it's not even because you're
doing intense exercise or restricting
your calories or doing both it's most
likely because those High Cor levels
increase hunger hormones increase
Cravings increase emotional eating and
as a result increase excess Chlor
consumption and on that note thank you
again to the team at unlocked for their
support on This research if you like it
be sure to give it the thumbs up or a
dirty finger up whatever works leave me
a comment below about who or what you'd
like to see me talk about next subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen
bye